silver State's Credit Union the sponsors
of our next segment always put people
over profit they want their members to
experience to achieve financial success
and Mercedes spoke to them to find out
how they're doing just that
we are so excited to talk to Silver
State Schools Credit Union CEO Scott
arkles welcome back to the show Scott
hey Uncle Mercedes always good to be
with you we were talking last time about
Silver State Schools Credit Union's
30-month certificate account promotion
is it true that members can even earn
more in October yes in October we're
actually glad you asked because uh
absolutely Mercedes so at Silver State
schools trading obviously we strive to
provide products and services that help
our members Achieve Financial success
and one of the biggest and most
important habits that we always want to
promote is that is that they are safe
and so to help them save and earn more
towards their long-term savings goals
for limited time we're going to offer a
15-month three percent uh annual
percentage yield with a minimum deposit
of 500 and there are some restrictions
that apply although there they're not
tough ones and those uh details are
going to be available by visiting
silverstate2u.com provide visiting any
one of our 10 branches that is
absolutely incredible I'm so excited
about that you guys are always giving
back not just to your customers and to
the members but also to the community
and this month Silver State Schools
Credit Union you're actually collecting
clothes to help to provide them to Local
focused schools how can the community
come together and help in these efforts
yeah I'm glad you asked Mercedes uh
cover speed School of credit union as
you mentioned giving back to the
community is extremely important and
that's why we created the Silver State
School Credit Union people over profit
Foundation also known as the plot
foundation so its primary mission is to
provide Nevada students with the
resources the tools and the access to
build a better future by doing uh our
part to educate and Empower them
um and and that's really to help enhance
our community and the success of our
community so on behalf of the plot
Foundation Silver State School of credit
union is collecting any new or gently
used clothing such as coats weather
socks undergarments shoes they have both
toiletries for school-aged children and
beginning Tuesday October 11th anyone in
the community can drop off these
donation items that any one of those 10
branch locations that we've got
throughout the Las Vegas Valley or in
Henderson so we've got that we've got
plenty of branches to do that you guys
make it so easy just go and drop it off
so definitely help support the pop
foundation and Scott thank you and for
everyone at Silver State Schools Credit
Union for all that you guys do you make
uh you make having someone in control of
our money so pleasant and you also give
back to this community it's such a great
experience working with you guys thank
you so much
thank you again to Silver State Schools
Credit Union for sponsoring the segment
for more information you can call
702-733-8820 or visit
silverstatecu.com we'll be right back
[Music]